hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast and keynote presentation
genomics in the clinic a revolution for
healthcare and medical research
presented by dr. Marcella finger-tight
Aquino's informatics at the garden
Institute a clinical research and
conjoint associate professor at UNSW
Australia
I'm Cindy Valdez collaborate and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're excited to bring you this
educational virtual conference presented
by labyrinth the leading scientific
social networking website provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
the scientific collaboration and
learning
here's how this presentation will work
today we want to hear from you questions
comments and even answers can be
submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen we'll try
to get to everyone but if not we will
make sure to follow up with you by noon
you can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you cannot hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking at the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button at the lower left this is an
educational webinar and this offers
continuing education credits after the
webinar kotoba please click on the CC
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits
without further ado I'd like to
introduce our keynote presenters dr.
Marcel Dionne welcome sir
everyone it's a it's a real pleasure to
be able to present this the seminar
today and thank you Susie for the
introduction okay so today I'm going to
talk about what what I've learned over
the last number of years in my role is
the CEO genome one and hideth the King
wanted to the clinical genomics on the
impact of genomics in both in precision
health care and in medical research so
let me start at the beginning
but getting for you with me anyway so
that's the moment of conception the
moment with an egg cell from our mother
and Scrimm cell from our father unites
the egg contains 23 chromosomes from mum
and the spoon contains 23 chromosomes
from dad so together and you may read
others from your biology textbooks when
you when you study just like there are
46 chromosomes that make up our genome
machinery genome each of those
chromosomes made from DNA DNA versus a
polymer so each chromosome contains
hundreds of million copies of these
students and these or letters that are
called nucleotides and their
representatives age pcs or genes so
together our genome contains more than 6
billion letters and this is really what
what forms the core of what we're going
to be talking with outside I feel it was
important to make that introduction so
this is all the information effectively
that like me to program a single-celled
embryo that's created at the moment of
conception to avoid in a perfectly
coordinated fashion in hundreds
thousands and eventually billions of
stem cells as the fetus develops in the
womb and instance human being every
structure in our body blood cells muscle
your nervous system our kidney bones all
of these things all programs and
operated by information in our genomes
this program repeats with such
remarkable precision and and as you can
see in the case of the identical prunes
here in the bottom of this slide that
runs almost consider irreducibility as
much you've missed I and hair color but
even down to the finest details of where
and when hair grows and how its open it
receives and how our skin responds to
the environment is all ultrafeed encoded
in our genome and context
zees when a DNA is damaged at some point
in our lives that's how the seasons such
as cancer and in the lichen can
eventuate now information is in our DNA
is also what makes us different all
those six billion letters of information
about 3,000,000 differ between you and
unrelated individual it's these
different things that make us unique
it's also these differences that can
cause disease and we've virtually every
disease or our response to disease is
actually encoded in our genome and so
this is really quite remarkable and of
course you can also see that in the
cases of of severe disease that can even
see one one damaging mutation that can
cause that can cause quite remarkable
leave and diverse sources diseases so
although our understanding of genetics
from the principles of inherited
characteristics dates back you know
about a hundred years accumulation of
Mendel and which will be familiar was
we've understood the structure of DNA
just over fifty years and it's only very
recently that that humankind has had the
ability to actually sequence DNA who
work at the order of what these letters
are it's just tiny fractions of small
parts of genes were able to be sequence
if now as possible in the two thousands
from really owning this in the last ten
years to sequence the whole genome at
this stage we only know a tiny fraction
of what that you know actually means and
what it does but the fact that you can
read a person's you know complete
genetic blueprints or instruction manual
in few life relatively quickly and
cheaply
is it anticipated to have profound
consequences on both choices that we
make in our lives and how we interact
with the health system so this is really
the beginning of this new era that we
refer to as genomic medicine and and
potentially here a whole new area in
healthcare more broadly so putting this
into context in the last this was a
graph of disruptive technologies that
was safer than the computer a year or so
they're going you'll see that many of
these technologies will be familiar with
our mobile internet and advanced
products cloud and self-driving cars
and those sorts of things but you'll see
there at number seven next generation
genomics has been one of the most
influential technologies or most
disruptive technology that we're going
to expect those of it in the coming
decade and actually slides so you'll see
that by 2025 it's anticipated a
next-generation genomics will be in the
order of a trillion dollar industry so
because of the list of disruptive
technologies the reason this one is so
significant since the attacks is only
one that has a real impact on healthcare
which makes it especially important so
this has been reflected in government
investments around the world in genomics
and in Australia where I'm from
somewhere around in the order of around
100 million has been devoted towards
developing genomics and in healthcare
but around the world
the these figures are actually much
greater with in the order of 100 million
spent in the UK billions in the US and
China and and somewhere around close to
700 million euros from France all
towards an investment in the equity and
understanding the role of genomics in
one care so whatever the opportunity but
if it makes genomics such an onion so
special - contestant healthcare well
first of all when we look at it
I guess it's most immediate impact it
was clearly in the diagnosis of rare and
in genetic disease let's make sense you
know if you think about genetic disease
we're able to sequence a genome that
follows that we're going to become very
very good at diagnosing to this disease
within a single test read this
information so we go to cancer and the
opportunity there frequent consumers and
being able to impact student cancer
results it was also obviously a genetic
disease a case where the cells in the
body as starting to divide in ways that
are uncontrolled because the genome has
basically be older than instances and
ultimate in a way that not supposed to
and by being able to define the exact
biochemical
the molecular basis for what's happening
in that to know that we rode is my
favorite kind of it's treatment the
direction that the science is going in
and then finally there is a view that it
isn't that the capacity to be able to
sequence a genome in advance attention
disease will have the most profound
consequence at all and of all in
healthcare where we'll be able to
anticipate the susceptibility for
previous positions that individuals
might have for for cardiac disease or
cancer or a adverse reactions to drugs
so unlike other molecular tests what we
see with genomics is in technical Jefe
has an impact across your entire life so
right from you know from from planning
to have a child in the context of a
carrier screening and working out you
know which individuals may have a
recessive disease that again would be
expressed in a child to be anticipated
all the way through to being able to
read and understand the information that
happen at the point of the fetus and
following that the child is born being
able to predict what what potential
health problems might emerge early on in
life that can be prevented
so the area that we're most closely in
is in the area of pediatric disease and
at the time but we certainly expected in
the future cancer diagnosis and even
eventually in the context of the
molecular autopsy understanding why it
is that widens if somebody died so what
made is this all possible is really this
dramatic shift in technology that made
it made it possible to sequence a genome
for far far more inexpensive even at
once even just ten years ago so ten
years ago it cost somewhere in the order
of a hundred million dollars to sequence
genome whereas following the development
of new technologies in the introduction
of nationally parallel sequencing in
around 2007 we start to see this hyper
exponential decrease from the cost of
sequencing the whole genome and then in
2014 with the release of the Illumina
instrument that Isis extend
it became possible to sequence the
genome for nowadays custom around about
a thousand dollars so we're sort of into
the same context as as other
sophisticated medical tests such as for
such as in our eyes so it's very unusual
to see a technology where you get a you
know a 2000 film production and costs in
the space of just a decade this is the
instrument that note is possible you
live in the hi-c kickstand which was
released in 2014 as I mentioned then
sequence genomes not only at a
relatively low cost but also in
large-scale about 18,000 a year or or
about 350 so it transforms this
technology really transforms the entire
data fixing market but is it actually
possible that all of these the previous
types of individual genetic tests such
as Sagittarius and opa in the between
gene sequencing become become replaced
effectively just by a single set so
rather than and this is transformative
because for a geneticist who's trying to
anticipate and which case to use you no
longer really need to do that
you just do one test and you have all of
your excavation and then it's really
just a question of what plants the
genome you need to look at so this is
transformative in there in the tunnel so
our own inverse and the specific scene
was that the the Galvan Institute is one
of the first websites in the world to
take on this technology service suppose
institutions and messaging so our Center
the one that I work in the 15:1 center
for clinical genomics and it was
established in about 2000 control and
and made use of both through so in
focusing and state government funding in
the mission of the center to because one
of one of only a few of this kind of the
world's really to bring genomic
information into whole of life
healthcare so to a very strong
translational processor so the
objectives were really translated the
technology of whole genome sequencing
from being a research tool and into the
clinic and ultimately with of users with
becoming routine diagnostic and of
course the other aspect that I'm going
to touch on in the store is also how we
bring together clinical information and
be able to deliver in a research setting
as well I think this is a significant
paradigm shift where we've traditionally
seen a real separation between data
that's generated in clinical context and
information that's generated in the
research context I think what you know
mix is going to do is going to bring
freedom seems much closer together so
our Center the fifth fastest in 2012 and
really the only thing I want to point
out here is just the the the
distribution of of individuals in this
translational process where we started
out of course we find for decisions and
technicians to learn to learn the
sequencing instruments but as we grew it
becomes as you can see far more heavy
towards utilization of fire schematics
and software engineering and eventually
also good clinical integration to be
able to take a technology that was
really developed in the research
environment and being else translated
into the clinical environment and what
we've achieved now I think through this
is a damico system where clinicians and
researchers can work very closely
together so if we take a more
traditional look at how the separation
between clinical research industry and
pathology influence appear formally were
where we used to in the context of for
example identifying a new genetic marker
we're in a patient cohort we have
researched this cohort and sequences and
in have you know identified something
new this was published and then at some
point industry and pathology might take
this on and show that the show that this
new market has kind of a utility and
limit might from their emergence which
mimicked this and then from there that
could be could become used and
translated into the clinic and I think
what we're seeing now in the enabling is
precision medicine this particular model
is not one that is is really going to
end that can't really endure in full of
realization for surgery medicine and the
reason for this
is that there are now so many different
things that you can test for that it's
very unlikely or so infinitely costly to
be able to run through the subject area
across thousands or tens of thousands of
different genes and when in fact what I
think we'll see is these fields coming
much more closely together and I think
really be I guess the philosophy of our
Center is to distance take away these
boundaries that formerly existed between
these industries and start bringing
things together into a common ecosystem
so where they're rather our thinking
with a patient research cohort the
research hub would also becomes in
parallel the clinical trial cohort the
basic research becomes translational
research and when you identify genetic
marker it becomes the genetic test and
in an environment where this becomes
possible you get in I get this
remarkable efficiency in being able to
translate research information into
clinical outcomes in a far more
efficient way as much as possible before
and at least in part this is what we
what we've been what we've been striving
to achieve in Greenup workers very
virtuous sort of a cycle where where
research can be translated almost
immediately and in transfer that's
really clear and in the same setting so
what makes this possible of course is
that you need to operate in a very
different environment fistful closely
miss clinicians but also secondly that
the test data that you're creating is
done in a in an accredited laboratory so
that information can experience winds
back to the clinic so this is what we
see the as a future model for how
healthcare may look in a few years and
into the future
so the idea that you're taking a look at
the top offices of this chart and you
can see that there is information from
impractical information clinical
information EMR data and so on all kind
of coming together into a common
database if you will or into a common
repository that could be shared and the
key things to make this happen of course
is that content needs to be done
appropriately from the outset so
regardless of whether or a reason
as a research participant or a patient
that they are consented to the
information to be used in this way so
you also need to put the clinical data
to the individual way that it can be
shared and manipulators and an informant
effectively where you can use it for
analytics and what we did expect the
mature if it's the middle of part of
this is that it's really the genome that
forms the backbone of the information
that all of the slopes onto and that
from there we can use new machine
learning algorithm subsidized clinical
decision making in real time so what we
really attacked what we're really saying
here is that in the future what we
expect to see in a realization of
physicians healthcare is effectively
where all of the information that's
available about all patients in the
world is actually able to be used to
inform new decision-making so rather
than a research study necessarily
informing the next level of
evidence-based clinical care that
benefit in space is actually being built
at about in real time so that for
example the responsiveness to a
particular drug is immediately known
from its use around the entire world and
by matching the back up of genetic
information when a new patient arrives
that you're able to go okay this process
is going to be really effective on the
significant result and be effective and
that that data is actually available to
two dimensions in real time so we're not
there yet but certainly what what the
ambition is of of our system and this is
really the first exception this journey
was to be able to get at its most basic
for a clinician to be able to request a
whole genome sequence for an individual
entity only fillet a pathology report in
return that they can then act upon to to
guide the care of that of their patients
a very complicated process that there
happens to be through this I won't go
into systems a great detail but
effectively the counseling sense and of
course with the acquisition of clinical
information and and DNA which is in
sequence analyzed through sophisticated
bioinformatics pipeline and then
ultimately interpreted and
basically rapport so embarking on this
three or four years ago which was a
significant challenge the reluctance
that needed to concerned about who know
not the least of which was to have a
mechanism through which you know blood
samples can actually be taken from
anywhere in the population returned into
our laboratory so with the described
partnership a difference with an
existing pathology provider who of
course established the high-throughput
genome sequencing with the X n which
means talks to scale and were able to
start generating data at quantities in
around about a thousand genomes per
month
they needed a mechanism for you to
create to capture phenotype so there was
a platform transcribe them but more
details shortly that enables a
standardized mechanisms before capturing
phenotype and of course quality with it
was fundamental illness we had to be
able to demonstrate that the specific
purpose the clinical use and and of
course we have this acts up through
clinical expertise for apartment lease
for the publica pathology provider a
diagnostic grants proved to be quite
exceptional with whole genome sequencing
you consider that the former
technologies were able to diagnose
perhaps in twelve percent of individuals
what we found in whole genome sequences
that were able to diagnose around
without certain specific cases and
interrupting the most difficult of cases
of individuals that are affected by
their genetic diseases probably
management becomes fundamental these are
very different processes than what we
are familiar with in a research
environment being able to apply the
controller into a into a clinical
setting as well and leading alternative
accreditation and an alternate also
solution deliveries through their not
happening that ease that we formed
called genome one so effectively what we
achieved through the essa was a very
harmonious relationship that's been
developed between the Garvan Institute
in genome one is to enable this cycle
that I described before
and it really puts a student minor in
the position where tables require
clinical based genomic information and
musically either diagnostic for research
purposes so the remainder of my talk
I'll just talk a little bit about our
how we approach this in the context of a
disease diagnosis but not forgetting
that genomics has potential across a
very wide range in health care so why
rare in here is a disease so in
Australia of instance that one to one to
two percent of Australians got born with
severe genetic disease Romania butchers
are are undiagnosed diagnosis can by
treatment is a very valuable process for
for patients and for families and as I
said the diagnostic yield could be very
high in this in this space and of course
because this is a relatively and a small
communities and solve a very significant
community it's possible to turn some of
this and in the health system by and in
this focus in the terms of genetics
arena so and of course there is a very
strong economic case for the
introduction of the technologies so even
were able to make some real personal
impact on on individuals there in Japan
see here Sicily the mother of one of our
families that mean you're able to
diagnosis for that had got to and really
a remarkable journey of of negative
tests effectively and treatments that
were ineffective
so eventually come across what we were
as achieve hold you Dempsey configure be
able to provide a diagnosis and huge
impacts on the family and aunt hedaan
many others so coming back to what makes
this so difficult and where the
challenge sister today in terms of being
able to generate the data is something
that can be done now quite routinely
livid instruments but the interpretation
of these six billion nucleotides of data
is fill a huge challenge so between each
of us is about 3.2 Rockies with 50
million variations between us but each
of us actually carry happy you know
around about 100 or so genes that could
be considered as the
beginning which is remarkable and
somewhat unexpected but it makes it
actually very difficult sometimes
identify what the cause of the disease
is when in fact may be a healthy
individual also has a number of defects
and genes that don't seem to actually
have such a direct effect so this
effectively this culturing that we go
through is really what the the magic is
that happens if the diagnostic level and
look in the interpretation laboratory we
take these three million variants and we
run them through a number of different
databases and filters and computational
algorithms and ultimately in that verses
number between 50 to 100 and so of
different mutations that we then try to
analyze and try to connect with the
disease one of the really important
steps in doing this is is if it's
abusive abusive phenotype so as you can
see this in this photo here phenotype is
a core driver for how we actually
interfering so what that means is that
we need to have quite detailed
information about the characteristics of
the leads we're looking for to be able
to get the real childress of our
variants that we actually believe a
causative in the disease so in this
particular example these are two
unrelated boys you can see that they
have some very similar characteristics
so those the Delta importance of the
mouse and low City is in a couple of
other policy papers books some are these
two boys are unrelated but you know some
people see this photo and mentholated
almost these others so but in fact what
happened was is that this was a a case
where one of the boys had been had a
theory is a potential gene and causing
the successive attacks one gene that was
caused differences in businesses but it
has never been seen before so without
having another case it made it very
difficult to ensure that this was the
correct gene that was causing the
disease and what happened in an ad hoc
section is a citizenship at the
conference the story goes and there was
somebody else in the audience or stuff
but a child and
my clinic who looks like they have
similar characteristics and sure enough
they tested that same gene and they had
the identical mutation and so our
diagnosis is safe now in the case like
this this happened by effectively by
serendipity and what is now trying to be
coordinated is how we can actually bring
these types of cases together so that we
can more effectively and and more
efficiently diagnose rare diseases so at
the moment the world it helps this kind
of looks like this fear cadet assists
will often speak to each other and may
just phone one another up or or leaders
conferences and it was just wasn't a
very as I said up here after this round
of an ad hoc way for a diagnosis
creatine so what we aim today is Co try
and share feed a typical information in
an automated way in the same way that we
can share genetic information
so unlike the genome which is going to
force a very standard language a so you
see the genes degrees to represent them
so a common way to represent data for
phenotypes to complicate and in fact
phenotypes from you know use descriptive
terminology that's happened
nonsense eyes so what the real aim is is
to be able to really understand the
genome we need to be able to extract
this information from what we call the
phenome which is the collection of all
attributes that occasionally order
physical and biochemical characteristics
that are expressed by our genomes that
phenotype and so and ultimately we want
to be able to bring this information in
terms of how how the environment affects
impacts on senior class as well as for
bringing together of this information
that students could it fails accidental
course phenotype so to the senior
developer platform between professional
inspection archives which effectively
uses a standardized terminology set from
the Cuban phenotype ontology that
extract and that can then be used to
standardize the clinical notes and then
be able to share this data
so let's talk to this briefly the key
features of the office platform and
technologies that are able to take
clinical summaries and notes and be able
to extract the standardized human
phenotype ontology from in so for
example a terms like like say large head
would gets turned into macro syphilis
for instance and some big Gators would
also become sacrificially and so you can
sort of start to take normal language
and it can be translated into a into the
clinical terminology and then this is
what the information that can then be
shared into databases and then other
submissions but instead of better they
can then use a common language to be
able to to interact and potentially max
patients together and that's really the
idea of this of this technology and it's
been working very effectively in this
context so the view that we are trying
to build towards is actually trying to
integrate genomic and phenotype
information either in a centralized or
in a or or if in some sense a federated
manner which is actually really SAP some
networks of genomics and genomic
information and from that collectively
we can both better understand what
characteristics can be learned from the
genome and person specifically become
more effective at advising disease so
listen to the I guess those of you that
we're that we can develop through the
specific an individual has a phenotype
captured a genome sequence and this
intervention is centralized the
information that can be interpreted
clinically in the mutant collection and
the information that we don't yet
understand can be used to to research
and to identify new knowledge and
therefore building new gene ephemeral
genotype phenotype associations with the
genome so the idea
here is that progressively we start to
learn more and more about how how the
genome of informs casino courses creates
issues big data problems the defense of
my talk I'll just talk a little bit
about where I see this going in the
future
so certainly genomic pathology is really
just the beginning of this process of
this journey and in the context of
really the sources where we started but
there are many other major diseases that
are had a massive impact on the health
system including for example kidney
disease and cardiovascular disease that
has a strong genetic basis for them and
where knowledge of genetic information
and potentially informed patient
medicine but really as I said it has
this impact across all walks of life of
whole of life here impact where at some
point in the future perhaps when a
genome sequence perhaps the first where
that information sees we query again and
again over the course of a person's life
[Music]
to form different parts of what's
happening at that stage so for example
if you get cancer then the information
might be used to anticipate what the
best treatments might be or in the case
of enables drug reactions or before
having a drug then you're able to
predict which drugs are going to be
effective or which one can be made as an
adverse reaction to so I get the other
two the interesting thing that this
creates about the genome is that we end
up with this graph where the cost of the
genome continues to come down and the
value of the demand continues to rise
so as we sequence more genomes and more
genomes are connected to health
information which are to learn more and
more about what the genome can project
and we become I think more powerful at
being able to extract information from
the genome so at some point we're richer
with the sort of sisters cross
we're designed to protect where you end
up with a farm where you know this line
has already been crossing the in the
cross in the context of rare disease
it will start to cross at a time goes on
until you consume more and more
different types of diseases and
eventually the anticipation is exactly
will be value of any individual to
achieve in sequence so the figure there
on the right just shows the the number
of genetic low-side that's convenient
but connected to a disease is the
complexities like schizophrenia and you
can see this even over the last five
years
where in 2009 almost nothing was known
about the genetics of schizophrenia and
there by 2014 hundreds of genetically
science in sympathy for this disorder so
in this sad story homes across many
different diseases and they're learning
more and more about these all the time
so we expect therefore that you know
it's well expanded to probably call home
of life health care management with
we're really a part of healthy aging and
and being able to optimize not only what
God should take but what what food you
eat and and and what other choices you
might make of your myself here in
science didn't happen upon by genomic
information and we are seeing this rapid
growth in our understanding between
genetic makeup and in characteristics I
think if the data continues to grow
we'll be able to become better and
better selecting live scenes you know do
it that already been shown that the
capability to be able to be perfect
detailed features of an individual face
and Julie from and other characteristics
are highlights potentially from
something known as information just like
the marker is in fact that was hoping
the future so but it's a long journey
ahead before we're there and this is a
nice figure I think that really
illustrates exactly what what's what's
happening with this so you see a [ __ ]
piano review so in the top left corner
of this obvious diagram you'll see that
monogenic disease which is where we were
really the the most readily accessible
mechanism to be able to
to diagnose disease sits in this area
this is where a single mutation will use
a an extreme effect that's what we've
seen Mendelian disorders but as we go
down the chart from top to bottom
you're not going towards more complex
diseases where there is a greater and
greater environmental component and so
we accordingly get diseases or or genes
rather that can have mutations in them
that will have a different impact on
different individuals and that can be
cleaned on what other genes they have
and the mutations that they carry and it
can also depend upon what environments
over exposed to so good example of this
is like the packaging with the RCA genes
which of course is a high predisposition
to breast cancer but not everybody that
carries the vector gene get first cancer
in fact I need to be nice to know you in
the theories from even different many
different backgrounds from 50 to 85 or
so to think the reason to persist or
treat some that may be environmental but
certainly some of that will be because
some individuals carry other particular
genetic variants that that prevents the
cancer from forming so this is really
what what is now trying to be understood
and I think will be understood as we
learn more and more about the genome so
to achieve this and this is really the
advent of a whole new field with the
application of machine learning and
people they seek data analytics in
genomics and indeed they're already
companies that are formed that are
starting to to take us on scale these
are seriously big data problems and will
no doubt require new algorithms to be
developed and and and I expect you see
the computers people around the world to
be able to manage and produce this
information because the scale of the
data becomes really quite remarkable at
this stage and at this point either we
don't fully understand how information
is encoded in all parts of the genome in
fact our understanding of the genome is
really restricted to perhaps one or two
percent of the genomes that we are able
to observe it accurately and much of the
other
the genome so called non non-coding DNA
parts of the genome much this remains
very challenging screen surfer so the
national initiatives that are moving
forwards for example in the context
specific genomics England sequencing
100,000 genomes but we're going to see
now is this development of mechanism
stupid to through scalable store and
share data but in parallel to all of the
genomics technologies that we're seeing
that we've seen emerging something else
is happening in parallel Z is this
explosion in mobile health monitoring
technologists where it's now become
possible to measure a lot of action you
know in some of these these technologies
are in clinical grade which which you no
longer need to necessarily goes for
clinics to be able to take every type of
measurement in fact the surgeons are
entirely new opportunities where instead
of just getting a snapshot of your
health information you can actually get
certain cuts and health information
monitored in real time so it goes well
beyond just pulse rate that means you
might do with a bit of something that
what you can but you can actually do
with real findings we Jesus in systems
for monitoring blood counts and neural
activity and so on is becoming more and
more part in this longitudinal
information once correlative against the
genome they become incredibly powerful
for learning and anticipating disease in
the future so we suddenly see the
genomics is employed to catalyze a
revolution and outlet and a decision
support and potentially even mobile
health and so this is I think really at
the start of a of a remarkable journey
in a transformation in healthcare that I
think will be edited safe driven by
genomics but but deeply connected into
into many other new technologies that a
federal energy we see certainly from our
perspective this is going to impact
across the entire health system police
isn't just for driving diagnoses of
research but it actually has real public
health impacts as well as allowing
[Music]
the health economics to actually do
bribe fishermen policymaking in ways
that were that we're never possible in
the past and it may just provide at
least someone's announcer through the
continuing burgeoning growth of health
budgets around around stifling the
individual countries around the world
that are becoming rapidly unsustainable
so to finish with these are really
different versions that we receive from
that whole genome sequencing is a the
single tests that can essentially
diagnose any heretical disease and
tailor drug choice and a concluded
health outcomes dude
absolutely anticipate that a test
sources of this power particularly as
information value continues to increase
so ultimately become part of a health
record and build the common Central
School in decision making for the clinic
the fileted almost challenge and taking
this information apart and and in the
deal with this bull decoding genome is a
long way to go there are millions of
variants that we do not yet understand
what role they have on our health really
what they do so that's something I think
that will emerge through as I said of
our advanced information any other so
the other ethnic interesting observation
around all of us is the development of
and what we've really seen in action it
was close and wonderful disclosure with
the gap between the clinical and medical
research communities in a way that liver
has been really occurred before and we
were now using the genome as a as a
common backbone or a substrate from
which both health care and research
seems to be mutually benefiting and
growing from nothing is can really lead
to a will is actually a fundamental
component of what will enable precision
medicine in the future and in fact I'll
finish and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you so much for that informative
presentation dr. Dina we want to begin
our Q&A segment so here's a reminder of
how audience members can communicate
with us questions can be submitted here
the Q&A button at the lower left if we
are unable to get to your questions due
to time constraints dr. dinner will be
answering submitted questions via email
so let's take our first question um the
audience member would like to know you
described the use of genomics mostly for
diagnosing diseases what can that Gino
tell a well person about their health
question so and I think that the that's
a great question thanks so I think the
at this stage it's still early days and
since I see the information that's
that's valuable to inform the health of
most healthy individuals however the
result is clearly we can read report
valuable information in the context of
cancer predisposition cardiovascular
disease and in another domain
pharmacogenomics which is he predicting
me but because the metabolism and and
reaction to drugs in pharmaceuticals so
I think that's a that's probably where
it's starting today but it's completely
seated in the future areas like area
testing I think are very valuable and
and being able to anticipate too
difficult diseases and many of these
have actually got really valuable
clinical interventions so you know
obviously in the case of cancer cardiac
disease or cancer we're more grief
illustrating for example might be
recommended for somebody who has an
unusually unusual predisposition to a
disease so we're starting to see this
emerging
thank you so much dr. zinger we have
another question from one of our
audience members he'd like to know as I
understand it only the small amount of
the genome can be used clinically why
did you choose the whole genome
instead of exons or pounds
interesting question so it certainly is
the case that using exomes or panels are
a very effective today in diagnosing
some types of disease our motivation
really for using whole genome sequencing
was that it provided an opportunity for
taking all of those negative cases the
ones that weren't able to find a big
diagnosis and then being able to put
that information back into a back into
the research environment if the
rationalism said if we don't start up by
sequencing the entire genome we are
obviously limiting ourselves and what we
are able to learn so to build this
ecosystem that I described between
health care and research I think we need
to civil previously gather information
that has those clinical and research
value in the whole genome is a a very
practical way of of doing that and of
course the price gap between the exome
in the genome continues to become
smaller and smaller and so there is of
course an anticipation perhaps that we
will eventually see that whole gene and
sequencing will be a very similar
privacy and costume to the exomes
thank you very much doctor dinner as we
end this presentation you have any
closing remarks you'd like to share with
the audience in a tremendously
informative presentation I would look I
just like to thank everybody again for
taking the time to listen to this
presentation and and I hope that you
found this an interesting way to start
thinking about how health care and and
medical research might really start to
have a deeper intersection and how this
feature of precision healthcare is
really required the efforts from for
both some both of these industries to
come together to to really realize
exciting time is pretty exciting time
and we want to thank you again dr.
Weiner Thank You audience I'd also like
to thank leverage for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available on-demand
viewing through August 2017 keep an eye
out for an email from labyrinth alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we really encourage you
needed for words and announcements to
your colleagues for me exist today's
live event thank you for joining us we
hope to see you next time goodbye